appreciate you so much fighting for us
because I want you to know now I love
you more than anything and I feel like
the luckiest girl in the world
Holton and Cassie are in love but did he
lose his virginity and gentlemen
marecus isn't else on Part two of The
Bachelor season finale Cassie and Colton
reunited and the pair decided to jet off
to Spain to meet up with his family
after last week I didn't really expect I
didn't really know what to expect Colton
finally got his overnight date with the
blond beauty last night with Cassie was
absolutely incredible we did what was
best for our relationship and we grew as
a couple and although there was not an
engagement in the end the couple is
clearly very happy and finally on the
same page and I think to myself I love
you when I just let myself feel I
absolutely love the
crazy I think I found someone I don't
want to be selfish for and I wrote that
so early on it blows my mind another
exciting reveal Hanabi is our new
bachelorette four season started right
away maybe you met the love of your life
maybe says so it wasn't enough to just
start your journey you said you know
what let's hand out a rose there are no
rules
so let's hand out our first rose and
Chris Harrison let Hannah hand out her
first rose of the season a franchise
first this is one of the hardest
decisions I've made this season camp
[Applause]
I also don't know how to put this like
ladar Colton and Cassie it made their
first public appearance on Jimmy Kimmel
Live where they opens up about the
future of their relationships so you
guys are are you can I should I say your
girlfriend a boyfriend or what is are
you lover would you consider yourself a
B lover future wife and Colton had us
all on the edge of our seats
when Jimmy surprised him with this and
part of the deal is you get the ring for
me Elaine so this afternoon I was like
this kind of sucks they don't get the
ring from the Elaine so we called me
Elaine and so here he he sent the ring
yeah so that's so you don't have to I'm
not asking you to do anything unless you
want to get posed to me
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
not only can it hold on to it
but it new it's really it's as no joke
that's a real in fact take a peek at it
Colton yeah so that is a really yeah for
weird
[Applause]
[Music]